gang that state trashy tour is plowing
through the country oh baby do yourself
a favor get your tickets at all you
garbage.com Kippy where are we going uh
we're starting off September 19th we're
going to Phoenix and we're going to the
Comedy Works in Denver another show in
Denver Salt Lake City Los Angeles San
Diego a second show in San Diego then
we're going to Washington DC Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Buffalo New York Toronto
Canada Toronto Canada third show in
Toronto Canada now we're going to
Pontiac Michigan we're going to Chicago
Illinois Chicago Illinois Chicago
Illinois Minneapolis Minnesota Madison
Wisconsin Milwaukee Wisconsin Sacramento
California Sacramento California San
Francisco San Jose Philly and Philly
baby get those tickets shows are selling
out left and right we want to see you
there welcome so another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is are you
garbage oh yeah it's that little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find that it's a group to be
classy but you're just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at titties in the new edition she's
upstairs little Mega Death okay a little
coffee all right relaxing plain or word
games having a nice nice time right
getting ready for the fall all right my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table this is a family episode I owe him
an apology for my ozempic burps uh the
past few days you've been dealing with
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan I
give it a reporter potty mouth everybody
thanks for tuning in as always side
effects please make sure you rate you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
obviously the greatest guy storm website
of all time www.patreon.com
garbage you go over there you can get up
to two bonus episodes a week baby also
all the [__] you get hard feelings
you get all the videos we've done a
whole bunch the short videos dropping
actually get a load of that and you get
tickies over there no that's at
rugarbage.com
that's where you get to town which is
also an amazing site and we also just
added a second Billy show Gang let's go
let's sew that
second third show is getting out third
show in Toronto I mean yeah the shows
are [__] selling out get your tickets
we'll see you out there on the road yeah
we're not pitching you scoop them
tickets up we want to see out at the
show's gang we love you to death I love
it people showed up there's only like
four people at the show we were just
lying the whole time which is a very
garbage move
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary old magic man he
likes uh grinding on Rails and humping
legs give it up for T-Bone and
expressions Toby McMullen that's pretty
good
the world's raddest dog yeah
man nothing makes me smile more when
they dress dogs up like that when it's
got sunglasses on and it's skateboarding
did you ever see the dog doing
construction man he's got the he's got
the trolleys he's flattening he's
smoothing out concrete it's a good time
can I just say you boys are really
showing the versatility of the black
T-shirt yeah this guy's stepping all
over my black tea listen I don't know
what to tell he gets one good compliment
and then he's like
then every time we're all he's like what
do you wearing I'm like a black T-shirt
he's like well I was gonna wear a black
T-shirt and we're gonna look like idiots
I go well I'm the black T-shirt guy my
plan is to muscle you out I'll be honest
not gonna happen I think it is it's not
because I'm prepared to look like a fool
for the next couple of months you've
been doing it for 42 years I don't know
why you're gonna draw the line now
that's what I'm saying it's fun because
you know you can dress it up with a
v-neck you can dress it down with a
shirt pocket sure how did you think
about that
I got right from the office to happy
hour wow throw me a pocket the problem
with that is you're not going to be able
to get your hands on enough good black
teas that's yeah that's always been your
problem you're gonna starve them out
yeah to give them to give them the short
squeeze baby we're gonna go buy them but
I'm gonna go to Every DXL on a tri-state
area squirting mustard on me
or at least lmd at a premium I'll go to
dxl.com and get a get them wholesale I
know but we've got a little guy over
there at the warehouse no we've gone
over this it's always different material
they don't always fit bigger guy clothes
don't always fit like they say they're
gonna fit that's why you're always
jammed up in like a purple suit or
something I really think
I really think in a couple of years I'm
gonna take a stab at Big and Tall
fashion design okay I really think I
could I could I have something to offer
the industry
from my personal experience free stained
clothes what are you doing
it's got a Kevlar crotch rippage oh dude
we were [__] we were we were
somewhere the other day in his [__]
his belt snapped in here oh dude I just
got back into it I thought it was the
button which would have been a little
early apparently dude it would have
ended the evening abruptly I would have
been walking around with a bathing suit
on because I only I'm only doing the one
pair of jeans he responded like I
thought he [__] himself or something
dude he went oh no and I turn around and
he's like standing on his tippy toes
with his hands in the air I'm like this
man just pooed himself yeah I had to
wash my jeans though because they were
getting too loose
it's not not real Gene fabric yeah
adding real denim
at Space Age Technology this kid's
rocking jeggings yeah yeah what are you
gonna do uh that's funny that reminds me
uh I was watching a movie the other day
were you shout out to the movie uh uh
what was it [__] Fargo Fargo I dude
yeah I was on a plane with him the other
day he was howling at [__] uh The Big
Lebowski man I've never said I don't
know if I've ever seen you watch a movie
dude you were laughing like a
middle-aged woman or Robin Williams you
were just [__] tackling over there
well you get to a certain point on a
plane where you get a little delirious
you're watching a moo you know I mean
you know big guy you're a big movie and
I don't watch that many movies on a
plane I'm doing all 90s from now on all
90s comedies and dramas I watched Primal
Fear sure great but I tried to watch can
I say this this might be real bad but
Christopher Nolan could pull it back
about 10 I'm trying to watch
Interstellar it's all
and then it's like dude [__] relax
with you Jesus I'm [__] getting dizzy
over here I tried to watch tenant one
time I had almost [__] fell off I
don't know what the [__] was going on
people walking backwards and this and
that no dude that's a movie I wouldn't
even know intense I've never even seen
the pre the trailer that's so intense
that just misses me completely people
talking about how weird it is I go all
right take that off the list yeah all
right turn it off throw in the birdcage
got my [__] head on [__] that ain't
happening man
crazy I love them don't get me wrong one
of the most brilliant directors of all
time but God damn [__] McConaughey
sweating it is and that's like Jesus
Christ try a couple decafs yeah
um but I was watching Fargo which takes
place in what the early 90s probably
something like that early 90s uh which
fantastic film by the way shout out to
it it'll have you talking like it'll
have you talking like that for the rest
of the day it's our deal Jerry this is
my ideal Jared
ah man but they were cooking uh she was
cooking at some point in the movie
and she was using these and it blew I
did I never thought about it huh but
this was it and this is a staple oh in
the 819 I gotta send it to Toby this is
a staple in the 1990s and 1980s probably
maybe even before the Corning was the
Company Corning I believe so give that a
goog T-Bone can you look up Corning I
believe it was Corning serving wear I
think you could throw those [__] in
the oven too to be honest with you oh
yeah yeah you can cook in them yeah when
something came out of that with the
glass top on it
but that green that flower that's
reminiscent of the 70s we had yellow the
bottom one sure ours would be the the
flowers or stars or whatever they are
would be yellow uh man I'll shoot they
got a whole set for their wedding and
man me and my brother over the years
just broke one by one oh yeah until it
was just like the soup bowl left there's
still there's still two or three
floating around at Denise's house
they're nice that'll still get filled
with corn or whatever we had the ones
with the handles that had a glass thing
and she'd put it she she might still
have it she puts it in the oven she does
baked beans in them man then then this
is another one this is another [__]
blizz ass from the pizzazz that thing oh
forget about that's what I'm talking
about yeah we have that yeah sure going
around yeah you put some scalloped
potatoes in that
little mac and cheese talking about home
run that stuff was a lot cooler back
then man a lot of that [__] they just
bought from the neighbors what some bro
somebody was moving somebody no no it's
selling it yeah they come around [__]
you get hit with that a lot of tuna
casseroles swapped out on a Tuesday that
was that was the casserole container
sure that's all that was Patty did two
great casseroles in her day and she
hasn't done them each you know I I
mentioned this door the other day she
used to do cheese potatoes on Easter
that would [__] they'd line up down
the block
sell out in two seconds cheese and
potatoes she doesn't she use Velveeta
too crazy good yeah just unbelievable
but yeah that blue one on the bottom
yeah that one that's a whole that's a
[__] yeah whatever was in there was
yeah green bean casserole from Denise
what am I an [__] with the [__]
French's [__] onions on the top which
I took me a little time to come around
though oh I love it they might as well
have been alien toes when I was a kid
dude I was not [__] with them things
cooking her fingernails his brother's
lost this broad's losing it now I like
those from jump but chicken all the
crumb is one that Patty did which is
bait it's all the same [__] it's
whatever mushroom soup and breadcrumbs
on top oh yeah chicken all the crumb was
a home run and she did a tuna casserole
with peas and egg noodles which stopped
the show she learned how to cook jail
tuna casserole peas and egg noodles
who wants Bruno
[Laughter]
is she making Hooch
those serving dishes pair so well with
salads in a Cool Whip container on the
side oh yeah yeah and two parents
screaming at each other
your dad already left what are the other
yeah
shout out to you he didn't take them no
no at my dad's in the early days there
was a lot of cereal a lot of Tupperware
which [__] nothing wrong with it
remember when you realize that you know
you had to have your license to do that
talk about thinking outside the box for
adults get a mixing bowl and just crush
a [__] bowl of Captain Crunch another
thing that was going around I actually
saw uh not too long ago it's like
there's like a meme floating around or
something of the wooden salad bowl did
you have those those things
I if I don't eat french are you kidding
me no but they were old school did you
have that I could picture your family
having them oh yeah and then me and my
brother [__] them up by putting them
in the dishwasher my mom was freaking
out tasting like Cascade for the next
five years it comes out all white and
grainy what the [__] did you do I used
to put it whenever it was a new coat of
stain on that put it back in the [__]
cabinet backer that up real quick
man
our our washing machine etiquette was
a light rinse throw it in the thing let
the dog lick off whatever got missed and
then close the door and let's go yeah
they're terrible with it terrible with
it Tuesday she'd freak out on us what by
not washing the stuff they're not doing
the pre-washing yeah we've always said
but we've always been a very heavy
pre-wash uh pre-wash fans put your
goddamn paying for nah but it when it
doesn't come out to me if it comes if
something comes out a little dirty then
you run it again yeah but now there's a
bunch of food in the bottom yeah but
then it questions
the it questions the Integrity of the
clean for the rest of the rest of the of
the whatever they're called some burnt
eggs on a pan yeah and you're just so
you put that stuff in there you put your
pans in there I'm anti that but the bird
will do it from time to time which I
don't mind but then it holds the it
holds the there's a film all you gotta
wash it before you make your scramble
yeah a little Cascade in there yeah I've
been doing this lately show show not it
won't be loaded fully loaded and she'll
wash everything and if I go to open it
and I kind of in the process of loading
it up if they're clean they're dirty
again I don't like that I love it that
was let it run it back I get yelled at a
little bit yeah but if it's if it's half
full and I start loading it I'm not
figuring out what I put in there and
what I didn't that to me and that I'm
not this is sometimes I know I know you
know it's clean no it's that to me is
why do that why waste the time
anything where you're going why waste
the time and the time is 35 seconds to
live like a normal human being
yeah no I did that once well the reason
I hated it was in college and uh me and
flip got our first real nice apartment
together in college and it had a
dishwasher and I was like I am we're
gonna be like these like real adult
mature people like a couple two lawyers
living together yeah that we [__] the
first week we did the first load in
there and then like never we then we
just lived out of that oh yeah and there
was like a couple of utensils or things
in there that just stayed in for like 70
Cycles sure to the point where I'm like
it's just such a reflection of like oh
I'm not doing well mentally living out
of the dishwasher and then just being
like loaded back in for years I lived
out of the dishwasher and the dryer oh
well the dryer I mean the best yeah it's
it's for that you would just hit that
for a couple of minutes couple of
squirts of water you're ready to go
throw a wet sock in there good night
yeah that's bad it's all right man uh
yeah no it's uh it's a thing uh a mental
thing I have with it where I have to
[__] it's a reminiscent of just like
a shitty time in my life where I'm like
I have to I have to do this for my
mental health I have to pull it out yeah
we never had those wooden bowls we would
do we would do a mixing bowl on the
table Yeah but the no not even the big
ones like the little one you would like
maybe you would go over like your
buddy's hat my buddy would hate me like
cereal in it in the morning I wouldn't
be like dude this is [__] wooden
spoon yeah I'm like there's just a civil
war it's just soaking in whatever with
their salad dressing in here we're not
at Antietam let's go no I don't [__]
with it hey quick to make with the real
bowls yeah Patty did do this though she
had you couldn't tell us nothing when
they first got married I think they got
a bunch of stuff as people do of course
but this is 78 or something like that
that they got this stuff you know what
we had that we thought we were I thought
I was again are you born in 76. I was
born in 76. so I got married after you
were born no no so it was like 70 that's
so it was it wasn't from that it might
have been but I remember okay that's
you're realizing that your parents were
[__] two chips in the night when you
were born Daddy's stepping out I was at
the wedding
um that's a real trashy thing too ring
bearer I was bartending
seven and seven I think for their
wedding they got a bunch of this stuff
and they put it away and then I remember
when I got a little bit you know two
three four whatever they started
breaking that stuff sure let me tell you
something
french onion soup Crocs
with the handle they had them dude you
couldn't I felt like we were opening up
a restaurant I had to steal them from
somewhere dude we had a whole set of
them they were up in the cabinet above
the refrigerator and usually around New
Year's they would break it out they'd
have another couple over and man my dad
would set that up that's nuts dude I
don't think I've never known anybody
that's had the French onion soup bowls
that's too much cheese you got too much
cheese in your diet if you got your own
french onion soup bowls dude that's a
lot of case Cindy had to have those back
in the day
I'm not saying you're wrong for having
them but I've never I don't think I've
ever seen that in part maybe like my
buddy stole one from a bar in college
dude that's one step away from fondue
and that's swinger [__] yeah I think we
have fuida fondue kit somewhere I don't
know if they ever broke it I think my
mom threw it out immediately I went to
confession I'm not a I'm not a
friendship
smashes it in the drive some Yuppie you
know what I saw the other day that I've
never been have either of you guys been
to The Melting Pot come on
no it's not just the right States of
America
no it's like it's a fondue place yes I
thought it was a restaurant it's a chain
fondue spot damn it seems pretty bad now
it can't be it's fondue at your table
though right you're not it's not
communal fondue for anybody with 9.99
would you want to a cheese fountain
no I didn't go I want to now I looked up
the menu dude fondue is top shelf that's
new guy Luke [__] he told us about that
that his family used to do fondue for
dinner could you imagine we did it in
school we did a chocolate and a cheese
we were like cool yeah but we were like
it was like we were learning about
Europe or something taking honors
courses
it was just me and four other fat kids
at lunch
no which was two hours for some reason
but I've done it with my wife uh the
Germans I think they do it in around New
Year's or something there's a cash
inflation they call it
um and it's great it's like that you
know they make them for your your home
table and it's like a little trinkety
it's not like you know don't they call
it racklet over there or something
Raclette I think Raclette Swiss is
originally Swiss that's like the big
melted cheese where they just body have
a sandwich topped with that when they
started going around the gram dude it's
a huge wheel and they just yeah I don't
even put that on a shoe and I'll meet
you dude let's go uh fondue's tight
though but they do it and it's like this
thing where it's supposed to take like
like dinner takes like four hours like
you sit down and there's you have your
own little thing and you can put
whatever Meats well cheese it like
whatever there's just a bunch of [__]
kind of like you're making your own
Tapas a little bit so you're just
sitting there eating drinking catching
heaters and dude I must I put about
[__] 19 pounds of cheese I can't put
in [__] for a month I try when me and
the bird go out I try to like relax
and like stretch it out a little bit but
man as soon as I'm done I want to get
the [__] out of there yeah you're crazy
yeah it always causes an issue I'm not
sure you've done my drink and I slam it
[__] you dump the road hurry up man
when you pull the wallet out and they're
still eating man they really that's like
dude that's just rude on your behalf you
shouldn't be going check while she's
still putting salt and pepper on her
yeah well I also think you probably eat
quicker I know you eat quicker I had a
Champions Pace
I gotta [__] call it the record books
uh you eat quicker and then
you do have the anxiety of like the set
you want to be gone which I get I'm not
I'm not there with another if somebody
did it to you
and say you were you'd be you wouldn't
talk to that person ever again I like
what you calling them every name in the
book I like to walk into the restaurant
I like that I like to sit down I love
the walk out all done walk out thanks
again man here you go that's where you
like to walk out in between other than
the eating part I don't like it that
much
yeah so what else is going on I'm
hitting with a lot of that what else you
doing how's everything else I want to
get the hell out of there who are you
talking to your girlfriend I don't know
I mean he didn't just meet her at the
bus stop what else is going on where are
you from originally maybe you're not
maybe you're not a great hang at dinner
either I'm surprised she's not running
out okay let's talk about DraftKings
shout out to him the kings of the draft
let's talk about seven long boring
months without the NFL gang DraftKings
and official sports betting partner in
the NFL is giving you a can't miss offer
for week one new customers can get 200
in bonus bets instantly when you bet
just five bucks on any NFL game all
customers can snag two new offers every
single game day this September let's go
yeah so download the app and see what
you get you download now use code ayg to
sign up new customers can take home two
hundred dollars in bonus bets instantly
for just betting five bucks I'm talking
five clams five benzinos whatever you
got a couple of shekels uh that's code
ayg only on draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL I ain't talking to fly by night I'm
talking the official sports betting
partner official of the NFL the crown is
yours baby king yourself you've got a
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler or
visit
www.1800 gambler.net in New York call
877 eight hope NY or text Hope NY uh
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for your gambling problem call
887-888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please pay responsibility on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resorts
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario c d k n g dot Co slash
football for eligibility terms of
responsible gaming resources bonus bets
expires seven days after insurance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply do it gang otherwise Let It Ride
Kip this is factor factor baby I know
you're a fan you know I'm a fan and I
know the long hair is a fan shout out to
factor gang it's the fall you don't want
to be worried about your meals you want
to get focused on Halloween Thanksgiving
what you're wearing for Christmas look
good feel good Factor meals has got you
covered stop the planning trip to the
grocery store the prepping the cleanup
Factor America's number one ready to
meet eel ready to eat meal kit delivers
Chef prepared foods right to your door
not only Chef prepare The dietitian
approved meals baby they're always fresh
never Frozen Ready in just two minutes I
throw it on a skillet shake it up it's
going to be have me in a Halloween
season I'm going as a [__] nurse this
year there you go uh I had one yesterday
the chicken shredded chicken taco both
out on the pants two two minutes dump
some in [__] low carb rap burrito
good night I'm a turkey chili gal myself
uh with over 34 flavor-packed options
each week meal times are always
delicious you can even level up with
factors Gourmet plus line that has
premium ingredients like broccolini
leeks asparagus look at that the fancy
stuff head to factorymeals.com garbage50
and use code garbage 50 to get 50 off
that's code garbage 5-0 at
factormeals.com garbage 50 to get 50 off
do it gang so what else
yeah like a [__] like an uncle who
comes around once a year the foleys we
didn't talk when we were eating back in
the day yeah we're at a restaurant I
don't know what my parents talked about
me my brother were just causing trouble
and getting yelled at knocking over
drinks knocking over Sodis sure yeah
there wasn't a lot of like yes yeah we
weren't like talking about politics and
[__]
no but you love a nice din I do love an
ice tendon it's got to be a real it
doesn't like people though it's got to
be a real select cast sure that I feel
real comfortable with who's more
comfortable than your girlfriend and
sometimes when there's other people
there
yeah me and her it's [__] out the
door
I'm running the show
that ain't great now I'm well aware I am
well aware Uncle Hank's a tough hey well
I'm well aware of the Vibes you throw
out when you ain't having it when we're
together we entree show if you pull up
the starter pistol
when we eat together it's real who me
and you yeah it's real older couple
who's over each other sure one sec we're
just we're just waiting for the plates
at the table well it's also yeah I mean
yeah but like we travel if it's just me
and you traveling somewhere it's like
we've spent nine hours of the day
together already yeah it's not like you
went and worked your job I went and
worked my job and then we came down
you're like oh you know what happened
today I want to start like we live all
day together and then we just do the
cliffs notes for [__] on people I
want us to oh yeah it's nice I want to
start doing the paper at uh at breakfast
I feel like that could really stretch it
out a little bit with who anybody
like if you and I you're gonna read two
headlines and then Dive Right into
Snoopy dude come on sure let's see
what's going on
see what Clifford's up to whatever it is
Dilbert see what Dilbert hijinks
dilbertson
nice paper some juice I'm not gonna sit
there and have you read the paper then
dictate me your interpretation of what's
happening around the world then I could
flip it down and say something to you
and then flip it back up yet nobody
wants to be on the other side of that
dude
I'd rather be eating alone
you're looking down your classes hey
what was that it's so funny you're not
interested in the news you just want to
prop for your dickheadedness yes
yeah yeah oh what was that and then flip
it up the second you're about to say
something yeah that's all right sure uh
all right all of that aside we got a
goddamn Family episode
as you know when you sign up for patreon
we will answer your garbage question on
here I got a lot of submissions patreon
obviously gets first crack at it because
we love yous uh we love everybody
patreon's all right uh this one's from
uh Jesus or hey Zeus I don't know never
have one red is it garbage if your mom
cooks the ATT technician lunch came
downstairs and saw this bozo in full
uniform tearing up some scrambled eggs
at the kitchen table
ew that's like obviously you want to say
yes if you're hungry you gotta eat it
standing oh yeah you can't have your
feet up on the cow she [__] them what
are we talking about I didn't even think
of that what
okay Jesus sorry to break the news to
you pal
but as long as you get free nights and
weekends who cares yeah and you're about
to have two Christmases so enjoy that
yeah [__] but again if the vibe's right
and I was in there
I wouldn't say no to a sandwich yeah you
would you would because you don't like
uh you're you I you want the sandwich
yes you would love to cook if it's a
house I wanted to live in
and like you got and she was like a like
you know you got a real good mom vibe
from her
I don't know I might I don't think you I
I don't socially you want it but you
just you don't even like sitting down
with me and eating lunch we're gonna
talk to this complete stranger it's
different psychologically I don't know
why yeah I don't think you will you're
not comfortable enough I could do I
could do the the I got 10 minutes of
small talk in me why wolf it down I
could see come across like a real life
it's gonna take 10 minutes for you to
finish Granby's come on five minutes
even better [__] you got them in your
hand popping them like aspirin uh read
the paper that's a tough look let's just
popping the paper down you know Patty
loves a man in uniform
I was sitting there the whole time will
you two knock it off
uh get a room already I'm reading my
horoscopes I used to love that was the
one thing I did read in the newspaper
sure just to see how full of [__] it was
yeah I never [__] bought into that
but I wasn't well I did Hook Line and
Sinker New York Post uh Sally something
really New York as a kid no when I was
young like in my 20s so I'm talking I'd
be like seven being like let me [__]
scope this up I would just use silly
putty on it that wasn't good that's the
only thing I thought I was a spy [__]
retrieving the classified documents
what's your sign I'm a Leo Leo classic
Leo Leo Leo daily horoscope married Leo
signs will feel the full effect of Venus
and I already hate this yeah no I'm
gonna tell you right now find out the
lady who does the New York Post it's
Sally something I want to say Sally
Brompton but I don't think it is it's
like Sally Abrams or Sally Sally
Brompton you nailed it did I yeah what's
Sally Brompton saying for Pisces all
right she's always good no matter no
matter no matter how annoying some of
the people you have to deal with today
maybe you must stay calm and always
react in a civilized fashion this broad
is way off yeah that should be mine
maybe just maybe move your more
agreeable attitude will shame them into
changing their ways I am I'm gonna be
more agreeable
Kevin
good to see you I like your shirt shut
up big head uh what's Leo even though
Money Matters are under excellent Stars
at the moment all right shout out to
patreon.com today's full moon warns you
need to watch your step when dealing
with people whose outlook on life is
more materialistic than yours that's you
and they won't hesitate to cheat you
yeah [__] sandbagging son of a [__]
I stole your car
oh mine's sick dude the only burials the
only barriers you will have to contend
with today are the ones that you create
in your own mind oh Jesus I'm like Neo
dude I just gotta free myself the more
the shrooms kicked in when she was right
the more you are tempted to believe that
a particular goal is beyond your reach
the more likely it is that you can grasp
it with ease there you go yeah sure I'm
buying a car I'm doing something this is
like psychic stuff to me it's like you
Jen just apply it how it Vibes you know
what I mean do you really buy into it
if it's good
like if it says good things are going to
happen should we get a psychic Tacoma
that would be no that would be a nice
patreon episode I would love that no
read our tarot cards [__] that did I
remember I remember back in the day
there was there was this comic she would
go around trying to read tarot cards I
would put her to Chokehold yeah dude she
started dealing something that was like
the king of death guys like later I'm
out no you're not finishing that nah you
didn't mess with that what are you nuts
get out of here yeah I had a girl
dumping garlic water on you I had a girl
garlic butter on her
[Laughter]
see a bunch of garlic bread oh God guys
I'm Gonna Eat This Witch nah you don't
you don't do they open portals and stuff
like that you don't know what's going
home with you and following you around
you don't mess with that [__] if
psychics had the ability to as you say
open portal they don't do it on purpose
they don't know what they're doing and
then all of a sudden they let something
in and then next thing you know my
head's spinning around in the bedroom
and it's never happened anywhere it
would be a billion dollar industry if
they could do that I think it is they do
well no but like each one would be
making a billion dollars psychics and
mediums now you don't mess with that
stuff no no
I don't [__] with you're more of an
extra large kind of guy there it is
also I gave you a compliment extra large
is pretty good be a skinny mini thank
you sir
um I don't know that would be fun I had
a girl read my heart she was like trying
to read my palm but I was in first grade
on the bus I'll never forget moisturizer
are these boogers or your lifeline and
she told me I had a short Lifeline I
hate that I know which one that is I
don't know if mine's short or long
freaks me out I almost [__] punched
her dude I was I was like what do you
mean short and then it was her bus stop
so she got off I was like you [__]
get back [__] you doing sounds like she
was doing real well
I was for I was in first grade you let a
first grader do it I mean she was
probably third grade Colleen she had a
red hair let her drive the bus I see how
good she is get the [__] out of here
dude it's stuck with I think about it
probably once a week yeah and as a kid
I'm like a short
I'm gonna diet nine or like 30 to like
what shorts yeah also I'm like I don't
think you should be authorized to be
telling people no not a doctor she read
a book or something yeah no I don't [__]
with that [__] but that would be a
really good patreon idea
come in and tell us our futures no I
don't want to know why now okay you do
realize that the pushback that you were
giving is why it's going to be so fun
what are we talking about that's why
we're doing it regular cards tarot cards
no regular well bring us I can hear play
Gin Deuces Aces one-eyed faces take a
jack of clubs and keep it moving
no thank you we'll talk about it I'll
just bring them in be like oh this is my
friend hey what do you think of my buddy
I would maybe do a psychic
if I could talk to some people oh a
medium yes
a lot of my friends and a lot of my
straighten some people a lot of my
family is trading some people out on the
other side you [__] tell that rat
prick
I know you [__] up
you know I loved it and you did it
anyway
tell that son of a [__] all right my
nana died and she never gave anyone in
the family a biscuit recipe
ask if it was cinnamon or nut Bank
she'd always play a hard ball at Easter
oh yeah there's that one dude on the
internet I don't know what his name is
he wears glasses he can guess like the
name of somebody that you knew man he
looks really [__] oh the guy who stands
in a room with 80 people going gym
now he [__] hits the whole name dude
you're seeing an edited version of it
you think they're actors no but they're
people look I think what happens with
this a lot of a lot of times is they're
people looking to believe and then he
goes anybody with it and then anybody
lose anybody with a cancer a lot of time
these people fill out [__]
questionnaires too there was a sixth
like a dateliner 60 Minutes on it where
like you go in and they have someone
like in the waiting room of like oh who
are you here for oh it's my son well
whatever and like they just passed the
information ah man it's like Leap of
Faith with Steve Martin you ever see
that
good film
good film I've seen the leap of faith
with Jamie Thomas God damn right yeah
deep cut I ever saw it porno
that was a skateboarding skin flick as
we called it back in the day nudie Megs
uh all right let's get back to it gang
this is from Russ uh have you or your
friends or family ever done a drive-by
with a paintball gun yeah with squirt
guns that's not painful I mean squirt
guns that's good challenge fun us
[__] paintball guns and assault we
ended up getting into a fight with the
one kid I felt bad for him
just some [__] kid walking home you
got hit with paintball guns or I'm sorry
we were riding we were riding around
with squirt guns high-powered squirt
guns like Super Soakers
okay I mean they weren't government
issues we were in the back of the
military and we were driving around this
one kid was like walking home we started
squirting them and then he said the
fingers he said something and we stopped
my one buddy got out and was like gonna
fight him and then by the end of it
we're just like apologizing I think we
gave him a ride home
felt bad
uh
we had you're a paintball rat probably a
little bit probably got all that [__] we
could never get that yeah a little bit
uh ours are called Splat guns I think
no yeah we did uh there was this
Robinson's like uh
Bait and Tackle where you could get a
gun for like 129 bucks or something like
a proper paintball gun they were they
were like pump action though okay uh and
this is like
mid 90s probably yeah it's probably like
eight or ten uh we had them and then my
all my brother's friends had they were
in junior high probably you know they
were probably like seventh eighth grade
and they were there was a couple of like
so not with like the can on it yeah yeah
yeah but they we we would use like the
smaller ones like the cracker Johns sure
yeah so you know them well
wow
that's a waste of gas
[__] couple of virgins running around
the backyard
[Laughter]
sure
um every paintball gun I ever
encountered never had gas
sure oh yeah oh we're out of the tank or
whatever pellet guns too who'd never
always had an empty cracker in it those
things look real uh we had do we looked
so we had a clip I remember and you
could fit 16 in the clip Jesus yeah and
we [__] man this thing was like an
actual gun [__] Snoop I remember I
just zoomed up Snoop Dogg to Dr Kippy
over here I remember when my dad got it
for us shook Ryan I'm like this is
I was way too young dangerous yeah and
he would just be like yeah go like we
just like there was like a pond pellets
man they were like an hourglass shape
yeah [__] you up we had the one
everybody had it was like the Craftsman
or with the Marksman or something you
would press the front and the front
would open up you had to be like there's
a rifle no this was a handgun I remember
the handgun that had the two little
things on the side and you pulled it out
that's that you would load that from
there yeah and then pull that the black
like that was a [__] nine million
yeah
[__] had the heat on there I had a
buddy of mine get hemmed up in a Wawa
with one of those
what you did was stick up he flashed it
oh yeah [__] cops were all over us
immediately yikes
I can hid behind a hoagie train I think
I didn't find my Super Soaker I could be
serving a nickel here I'd still be
locked up if they got those are
trafficking charges
goddamn straw purchase [__] arms
dealer over here
uh but yeah I mean there was kids that
would drive around with paintballs and
like [__] they shot up my house one
time those were bad kids that got that
stuff when they were little yeah no that
Patty had a line no BB guns none of that
[__] there were these things that were
like they were toy versions of them in
the in the late 80s early 90s called
Splat guns where they had like the
little balls and they had like this
little rubber thing inside we weren't
allowed to have that shed either that
[__] either you know what's [__] wild
I mean it looks like war that [__] those
aerosols isn't that airsoft airsoft
airsoft they have little gels in them
right no they are hard plastic beetles
yeah dude those dudes are like
full-blown like laser scopes and [__] oh
is that where they're like dumping it in
they're spilling it they dump them in
there that's paintball okay oh I think
they do that with the airsoft as well
well there's all these like uh Eastern
European dudes who have all these
YouTube channels where they put a GoPro
on the a gun they put a GoPro on their
helmet and they make like Call of Duty
style videos yeah yeah I've seen those
they're pretty sweet that's pretty
pretty [__] [__] these suits
running around isn't there one where you
can shoot Furbies or worbeez or wobblies
what are they called those things no
those are the things
uh what are the things like Mr Beast
like where are we Orbeez Orbeez I think
some do short shoot Orbeez gel blasters
they call them yes and they have like a
light so it looks like a laser coming
out they have a light when it shoots out
that's what they show you in the videos
and then some hunk of [__] shows up to
the crib oh really yeah they make cool
videos for tick tock and stuff and they
don't give you the real deal are they
called wurbies Orbeez what do they do
my nieces and nephews had them and I I'd
like you'll be like drunk at Christmas
and they just got like an Orbee gun or
something and they get real [__] they
turn into the bloods in the Crips dude
and I'll be like trying to I'll be I got
one code for a kitchen knife dude I got
one eye open trying to pour a Manhattan
of my third Manhattan of the night and
they're like hey Uncle Kev I turn around
they got they got me [__] hemmed up
I'm Behind Enemy line hands that over
your wallet and they they go they start
laughing and like it gets to that point
where I'm like if you shoot me with that
like why am I gonna be [__] I'm
really gonna be bad I'm gonna hate you I
wouldn't mind having for a weekend if I
was around like the kids and my little
cousins and stuff like that throwing
down on some serious Nerf Hardware
for a weekend would be pretty fun that
technology has gotten I don't know if
Raytheon bought them or what but that
[__] is pretty fun and those things move
can't what do you know about Harry's
shout out to Harry let me tell you this
shaving away this double shouldn't cost
you an arm and a leg gang with Harry's
you pick your starter set up at just
three bucks it's valued at 13. look at
that you're saving money already
includes a five-blade German engineered
razor with weighted handle foaming shave
gel and a travel cover you can even
schedule refills deliveries for as low
as two bucks talking two beans baby make
your entire shaving routine budget
friendly yeah it's fantastic Harry sends
it to you they open it up bada bing bada
boom he takes all the thought process
out of it and keeps my balls like eggs
baby you don't gotta worry these are
razor blades that stay seriously sharp
your eighth shave is just as smooth as
your first the weighted handle gives you
precise control so no matter what you're
going for Harry's has you covered uh
when you're done with your shave lather
up with Harry's amazing smelling shower
gels hydrate your face I lotion eye
cream body moisturizer the whole nine
yards from toes to the Head uh get your
best shave ever this summer with Harry's
razors and skin products get third get a
13 starter set for just three bucks at
harrys.com harrys.com garbage for your
three dollar Starter Set do it gang yeah
I'm back to the show back to the show oh
yeah you guys are gonna play Assassin in
high school no
let's hit a video game no it's a thing a
lot of high schools you live in a hotel
by yourself for a couple of weeks
what do you mean
you guys ever burn your fingernails
trying your fingerprints do you ever
track someone for three to four days you
guys didn't shave and dye your hair and
eyebrows yeah what what's assassin uh
it's where you get like a group together
and then everyone is given a Target so
everyone's hunting everyone else and
then it's like a game that can last up
weeks and you just sit everyone has a
Nerf gun and if you get blasted you get
their target and it goes until there's
one person remaining that's not bad it's
pretty fun yeah we would do something
like that with squirt guns
but not really like a game this guy in
this work guns squirt guns were really
pushing them on us I used to love
drinking at it and they had like such a
plastic taste yeah man it was great like
a bulldog on a hose
[Laughter]
literally holy keeps going I'm out of
ammo well quit drinking it you [__] I
got Mountain Dew in there I used to put
soda we used to put soda in them yeah
somebody on uh this is a deep cut but
Laverne and Shirley was a very popular
television show when I was a young man
and I think Lenny or Squiggy used to
have soda he used to have soda in a
square gun we tried filling up water
balloons with pee one time Jesus Christ
and we realized we couldn't
do it like I guess in our head we were
like oh we'll just pinch your tip we
didn't even get that far I was like oh
yeah we'll just like pee in a cup and
then pour it in I'm like oh you need
pressure to yeah to expand it you know
what I mean so I was like all right well
let's [__] put try to try to aim try
to aim your little [__] your shooter
up to the dude I was in my buddy's
bathroom and I peed and immediately the
balloon just flew out of my hand it's
just peeing all over his floor all right
I had the same experience with a condom
where I was like what are you peeing in
a condom I was why because I was an
idiot dude I was like 22 and I was like
that I mean still I know a lot of idiots
and they never been like oh yeah I was
peeing in a condom well whatever man I
was like all right I have this condom on
I was going to take it off and I was
like I bet I could pee it that'd be a
fun thing kind of full of piss sure and
then it started to inflate and then I
was like I've made a horrific tactical
error that's a time bomb you just have a
loaded gun full of piss boys
it was a hairy situation
damn that would be pretty fun though to
be honest it was fun for about three
seconds until now you're in a whole
situation yeah
Jesus uh all right let's see here great
question uh this one's from Bart haven't
had one red is it trashy if your local
pizza shop has a different box every
time you go
man I never they remember they used to
be branded most of them you'd get a lot
of brand or they always did keep the
same one yeah but then now it's I guess
after the pandemic all the shipping like
production now it's like yeah yeah you
get you go to Angelo's you get Dominic's
yeah it's all over the [__] place
yeah it sucks because there was a
nostalgic warm cozy feeling when you
know you're open up the Giuseppe's box
yeah now they just don't give a [__] you
like I remember like driving my dad
would drive I'd have to run in to get it
you come back out he like opened the
door for you know and you like get in
you're like dude I remember just staring
at like an Aldo's box for like you know
100 years a cold Friday night running
out of [__] Joe's Pizza getting in
the car with a [__] warm Pizza Box on
keeping the change too starving and just
the way that pizza smelled was [__]
Heaven two liter of Pepsi rolling around
on the floor man clean living I remember
one time [__] was all right where we
were coming from
I had the pizza on my lap and burn the
[__] [__] out of me dude it was like
so hot sure so I remember like I like
got home we ate the pizza and I'm like
my [__] let like like it like not
itch but like stung and I'm like what
the [__] I went up to take a [__]
piss or a shower I was getting changed
from bed to the inside of my thighs were
[__] bright red from the [__]
zabach God damn the kid up fat little
bastard called back on a free pie that's
what you get wearing shorts in the
winter Porky I don't know why you assume
was the winner
um all right let's see this one's from
Spitfire skater X that's a shout out to
my uh
uh yeah my screen name Spitfire 542 use
ever bring extra electronics when you're
staying at a hotel so you can fully
charge them on the hotel's dime I may
have brought two laptops an iPad among
others with me during my last trip Jesus
that's really
shocking this that's really trying to
pull one over that's one thing I don't
I've never have I've never worried or
paid attention to the electric bill ever
auto pay because my mom was such a freak
about it even when [__]
I don't know it never got that much I
mean also I was always in small shitty
Apartments you know what I mean yeah
it's also like a house I understand my
mom was such a [__] Nazi about that
[__] though lying about turning up the
thermostat or turning it down yeah go
over there and do the fake press like
press down
say come on lady [__] sweating my
balls off in here yeah uh uh I just got
jammed up at the [__] uh uh at the at
the house because we left for a couple
days and I thought I said it to like I
don't know [__] 77 or something like
that just so that'll ruin your month
what that [__] well yes oh we left and
then we got the first I forget what it
was my wife's like we used it was like
you know hundreds of dollars and I was
like what the [__] we were only there
two days last week or so two days last
month left that [__] wrong like clicked
all like so whatever run program they
have
predetermined bypassed my me setting it
79 or whatever
so it was just cooling the house down to
[__] 70 the whole time which I'm
jealous I wasn't at keeping the ghost
chili
uh all right this one's for me and P
ever get a party catered by Wawa
uh yeah
I think recently really Super Bowl
Super Bowl at my cousin's house she had
a [__] ton of shorties floating around
it was Wawa Chick-fil-A
and somebody else got in on it yeah it
was awesome
but is that just her ordering a bunch of
shorties no they do like catering gotcha
so like they come in like boxes and
it'll have like sure 12 tuna Hoagies 12
turkey Hoagies when you set them all up
nice that sounds like heaven dude dude
all right it was all right I don't mind
that I don't think I ever did
we didn't really do that many anytime we
did something catered
it would just be
at whatever Hall we were at right like a
Knights of Columbus or [__] VFW it
was Sterno City the sternos and it would
just be like
their kitchen made the meatballs made
the turkey made the whatever whatever
and whatever you know that's all I mean
home runs
I think too is our family is so big that
we would
it's not that much heavy lift while
there's a lot of people it's like all
right you're bringing this you're
bringing that you're bringing that to
like sure there's a lot of people to
just bring some and then it's [__]
you know we never had to call in heavy
artillery you know but I wouldn't mind
that yeah now I love that no matter
who's doing what at every family
occasion in my family there is
Chick-fil-A nuggets
there's one of those and there's always
a box of Philly Soft Pretzel Jones like
a little one I mean that's gotta be
that's Rel nuggets those Chick-fil-A
chicken nuggets are unreal
honor and they last dude we're breaking
those out cold later that night the next
day you're heating them up home run no
that's all right you ever seen one of
those oh yeah [__] throw down on them
that's the dude if you're there drinking
and then you're like you come home you
go out to the whatever you come home
later and you're [__] just a handful
of [__] nuggies you ain't got to
think about nothing I love all that
stuff man I love a [__] Sandwich Tray
and all that stuff anything in those
those round things with the lid that
never fits I love them
Good Times dude uh and that Philly soft
pretzel tray is [__] that with the
chi they for The Listener Philly Soft
Pretzel it's a company yeah or this
Philly Soft Pretzel Company or whatever
it's like now I don't know why
Philadelphia was so known for its soft
pretzels because Phillies or New York's
not that I mean New York has a super
pretzler like the big guy but that's
like the Super Pretzel soft pretzel the
company no they have like the big jumbo
ones like the hot dog guys sell the
jumbo yeah they [__] stink dude but I
tell you what family that had the Super
Pretzel soft pretzel box in their
freezer that dad was doing all right
yeah
I think in the opening of I think in the
opening of our show
you had one of those I think there's one
on the kitchen table which was all that
food was just in my mom's you were Super
Pretzel soft pretzel kid not really Toby
time to time we would be but it was
never from the frozen section yeah ah
that was viewed as trash in my family oh
they were great welcome to it yeah great
uh if I had my way all pretzels would be
soft right that's crazy talk but I don't
know why Philly in the South private was
maybe it's like because I know it's a
German I think it's a German thing
originally and I know there's a lot of
Germans
I got a really wordy article on a
website that looks like it was made in
about 1996. okay uh classic Philadelphia
soft pretzels are breakfast for many
commuters on the run that don't seem
right it don't seem real wrong
because before the sizzly at Wawa yeah a
cup of coffee and a soft pretzel
straighten you right out keep it going
through dinner
all those carbs I mean that throughout
the day this guy's talking about when
pretzels were invented in 6610 A.D
monks during the season of land every uh
early Catholic rules prohibited
consumption of dairy fats and meats so
pretzels made with just flour water and
salt fit nicely on the menu believed
uh uh it's believed early pretzels were
soft like the ones we treasure in Philly
today yeah they were because I remember
going on some Dirtbag field trip in
eighth grade where we went where it was
like old-timey [__] and they remember
they would have like the little shops
the fake shop like she's sewing he's a
black man yeah he's doing this he's
doing that and one of them was where
they made pretzels and the way hard
pretzels came around is that they left
the big ones in the oven too long gotcha
and they were like oh [__] we can Crush
these while we're watching football and
drinking beers uh-huh catching heaters
well this is actually awesome okay okay
okay uh
in 1850 bread breaker Ambrose Roth
obtained the recipe from a hobo as a
thank you for a hot meal and some
Hospitality damn talk about getting
ripped off that [__] hobo changed the
goddamn world
this is hobo doing let's get eyes on him
now pop who was that homeless man I
don't know Jerry but I'm gonna run him
over with the carriage later so it keeps
his mouth shut for sure gonna kill him
yeah he then Roth didn't pass the recipe
on to his Apprentice Julius Sturgis who
subsequently established the country's
first commercial pretzel Bakery
but for some reason in Philly Philly
used to like almost every large
intersection in the city had a guy
selling pretzels they would just stand
there with a huge box apart like they
would go buy their pretzels for the day
you know 100 pretzels or whatever they
bag them up in bags of three we've got
them in college we do that same thing in
college to raise money for yeah a lot of
yeah something that we weren't raising
for sure something we were [__] the
drug fund yeah but they would stand on
the corner and you just go it was three
for a dollar at the time or maybe like a
quarter a piece a piece dude the right
amount of dirt and grit on them the
guy's like [__] uh but I never and
I've known you moved up to New York you
can't get your hands on a good soft
pretzee
can't do it uh even I don't think
7-Eleven even has or maybe they still
have them in New York I don't think so
but the 7-Eleven soft pretzels compared
to Wawa as a philly kid they were
[__] pretty good they were pretty
good although I hated 7-Eleven I was a
Wawa guy but yeah that in a Slurpee good
night good night kids are [__] living
uh all right let's see this one's for
Mason is it garbage to order garlic
bread from a pizza shop for the pasta
dinner you made it home
I don't hate that this was like the
fries with the burger that we talked
going to McDonald's to get fries if you
make burgers at home I don't hate that
because garlic bread at a pizza place
throw some mozzarella on there very
underrated very funny yeah garlic bread
as a whole is underrated it's real
phenomenal those ones you get in the
freezer aisle that's in the silver like
the oh like the emergency blanket
the the bread that just ran the [__]
New York City marathon yeah they're all
right
getting comforted after a hurricane yeah
what but
garlic bread yeah dude I don't know I I
get it it seems like a good idea but in
my head it just it doesn't feel right if
you do it right it comes out soft not
that I'm on board with that I'm saying
going to a pizza place just to get
garlic bread to have with a dinner you
made
seems what did your parents used to make
I mean my stepdad would make garlic
bread my mom would make garlic bread
every once in a while and man we would
be like hyenas it was my stepdad's he
would cut like a big French or Italian
loaf yeah in half long ways yeah take
the top and then he would make like he
would take butter
you know fall out on some probably olive
oil garlic whip it all up and make this
paste and then [__] so it's also like
not that hard it's like butter and
garlic and bread which is most of but
the the trick is that you want it to be
soft and when my mother would do it it
would come out hard like the stones that
built the pyramids dude it was an
ongoing bit my mom used to burn a roll
dude sure crescent rolls God we'd be
sitting down then the [__] fire alarm
would go forget about them I forgot
about the bread yeah they're you're
scraping [__] black you're scraping
Ash into the just try to have a
Pillsbury dough Patty did that on
Memorial Day she left the big beans in
the oven too long and man I don't ruin
up that'll clear out everybody had to
either everybody jumps in the pool
there's yikes that is also a thing too
of like you try to you know now it's all
right this one's okay you know [__]
chip a goddamn tooth yeah crack a tooth
on a deviled egg
um yeah that is just a personal thing I
have wearing I don't feel like I can do
it for some reason although it does make
sense sure but I guess in my head if I'm
like oh if you're gonna make you're
making dinner
I get the french fries to nail a french
fry at home ain't easy you can nail
garlic bread at home or buy pre-frozen
made garlic bread maybe the place is
real hot with their garlic bread I have
had garlic bread that I have said
there's no way my mom can come anywhere
close to this sure we're also missing
the point in that we are not discussing
the garlic bread we are discussing the
Garlic Knot I believe no he's not red oh
you say bread yeah oh I was picturing
garlic knots this whole time oh garlic
knots for sure I don't love them I might
have said otherwise on the podcast
before but I think they're a little no
you've always been relatively they're
good
they're all right I do love them they do
like jazzed up a lot if you do the
mozzarella I feel like you'd have to
slice them yeah the inside stays a
little too doughy slice them and put
some cheese in there and then kind of
pinch them back up like little Garlic
Knot sliders half a meatball and some
mozzarella sure yeah but then this is
just a meatball slider
and
it's your [__] problem no but you're
you guys just turned a thing you don't
like into another thing that exists
that's just not that it's America right
there Welcome to The Melting Pot give me
yeah it's getting more fondue with table
three dump them in oh by the way the
Melting Pot website does not have a menu
it just has a lot of franchising options
they're really president burn and turn
that's funny remember we were talking
about that oh yeah about we were I think
we were down uh we were in Atlantic City
or something like that and there was a
sign for this shitty Italian place and
it said the first there was nobody in
there and it said franchising
opportunities available inside and it
was like oh you think you could do
better huh yeah we're tanking let's see
you take a shot take a step up to the
plate I love how it's also like what do
you want a sandwich all right how about
a franchise I came in to spend seven
bucks you're really upselling me with a
90 000 investment you could do a chicken
parm and uh you want to buy the place
yeah who's going door-to-door franchise
shopping any free any restaurant that
has franchising opportunity on it sucks
needs of needs a cash infusions that's
the [__] that's to keep the sheriff
off your back for a couple of days let's
talk about Robin Peter the number one
item on the Melting Pot menu is the big
night out
that's probably just a sorted of
whatever right it's a date night thing
but it's it's very clear it's like the
Capital Grille they're trying to be like
the upscale place by the mall
sure respect I like that check this
joint out um I could use a big night out
well for 14 more you can get the bigger
night out really oh yeah that's got
Lobster baby a full natto that'd be nice
you and your girl go out eat for 10
minutes and scream at her
Hurry Up This Is My Big Night Out
Francis Jesus
I'm holding the lighter under the pot as
we walk out I don't want it to cool down
uh all right let's see here this is from
TNS uh haven't had one read yet have you
or anyone you know ever discovered a
dead body Jesus Christ which is a trashy
thing because you're probably poking
around somewhere you shouldn't be poking
no uh no I've never discovered one I saw
a homeless guy frozen to death
out in front of the Chinese Embassy I
noticed as I was taking the change out
of its cup you all right buddy I noticed
that I was stealing his pretzel recipe
no I was uh I was living in New York and
I used to have to walk from second I
have to First Ave to get the bus to go
up to the Upper East Side and we lived
right next to the Chinese Embassy which
was a huge [__] building by the way
real creepy
um and he was it was a super super cold
winter and I walked by and the
detectives had just gotten there this
guy had frozen to death outside damn
yeah
huh no when I was an adult
yeah not drugs too
truth be told he thought the cops were
after you uh yeah I don't think I ever
I've mentioned before we were in the
woods we saw like a shallow grave dug
but that was it that was whiskers or
somebody that was somebody's dog no this
was a like an eight-foot [__] grave
really yeah a couple whiskers
uh yeah and it scared the [__] out of us
but you think they might have buried
somebody back there oh it looked like
they buried they dug a hole to put
someone in
it was like fresh dirt wait it wasn't
filled in the hole was dug the hole was
dug perfect coffin size you just missed
a whacking we're like out in the world
we're like deep in the woods you know
it's like kids
and we were like [__] Polly walnuts
and Chrissy walking around yeah we were
like what the we're like all right let's
[__] wrap this up all right no need
to build this tree for it let's go look
at these nudes in somebody's garage
exactly let's go to [__] Steve's
house steal some of those [__] wine
coolers now I never said that never
happened a lot of Dead Squirrels and
stuff like that when you're walking down
like an Alleyway and all of a sudden you
smell that oh that that smell of death
yeah I hate when you go into a bar or
something and you smell it like that
dead mouse somewhere or something you're
like this is gonna this is gonna ruin
this flatbread yeah yeah sucks
um all right let's see here
um this is from Jimson uh is your toilet
seat currently crooked or not attached
properly yes yes I think it's because
we're bigger guys yes we're we're Larger
than Life gentlemen and the pressure you
put down of sitting and turning and
blowing out lug nuts blowing out they're
not plastic they're plastic Clips I
would call them yeah and you can't
retire them because they just snap
yeah also sometimes I think in the
middle of night I pee on them a little
bit not like on purpose but like you
know if I got the lights off we got acid
urine no no that urinal [__] eat
through it after a while if you don't
wipe properly it's like a car down in
the keys that [__] salt choose right
through that
uh but we gotta wrap it up gang what a
fun fun hanging boys love a good family
episode uh-huh uh what do we got here we
got some guys some picks let's let's
plug the ticks uh we we added another
show in Philly which is [__] crazy
the venue's huge but we were [__] we
said let's live on the edge a little bit
so we [__] added a second show let's
[__] sell that baby out we appreciate
the [__] support red in the third
show in Toronto that's probably on sale
by the time this comes out we have two
third show in Chicago second show
Sacramento yeah third show in Chicago is
almost sold out Sacramento so get those
[__] tickets gang uh the live shows
are a [__] good time we'll see you
out there on a ride love you gang see
you next week peace